[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS Sports
NFL analyst and host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast you can find him on
social media at Ross Tucker NFL should
they have thrown the flag on the play
with cadarius Tony Ross absolutely yep
um I'm actually really surprised Dan
that Andy Reid and Patrick momes are
complaining as much as they are I mean
we still haven't had anybody say that he
wasn't off sides like like Mahomes is
kind of like yeah but it was such a cool
play it's a shame that they had to take
it away and Andy Reed's like I usually
get a warning like what are we talking
about Andy wants a warning momes just
wants it to count because Kelsey made
one of the most ridiculous plays I've
ever seen the guy was off sides and what
you know somebody has to have it uh Dan
I'm guessing CBS has it like I want to
go I want to see like 20 seconds before
the snap because you know how the
protocol is now right Dan I know you
know this okay the receiver they're
either on the ball or they're off the
ball if they're off the ball they look
over and they say to and they look at
the side judge and they're like I'm off
I'm off and and a judge will be like
okay if they're on they'll be like am I
good am I good and
if you're off sides the the side judge
will help you out like those guys try to
help you they'll say move back a little
bit no okay now you're good like that's
what happens so you know I'm seeing some
people say well kadar's Tony checked no
he didn't I mean he he didn't he didn't
follow the whole procedure because if he
really asked the guy he might have just
said to the ref I'm on and pointed that
I'm up on the B yeah no kidding caderas
you're not on you're so on you're off
sides you got to look at the guy and
make sure you're okay it wasn't even
close Now official won't jump in and say
to him in the moment like you have to
ask for confirmation from the official
he wouldn't say to Tony hey 19 back up
back up does that happen no because he's
in the
slot and the side judge is pretty far
away and it's not it's not the side
judges or line judge whatever it's not
their job to make sure that you're okay
if you look they will help you they
don't want to throw the flag they
actually give you like a decent amount
of gray area although because of the
brotherly shove this year Dan they've
made it a point of emphasis because of
what happened in the opener with Jawan
Taylor at right tackle being too far off
and because of the brotherly shove and
they don't like it so they're trying to
figure out ways to change it and they
don't want the offensive line for the
Eagles all up on on the ball they've
made that a point of emphasis this year
like I've never seen before so it's even
more of an onus on these line judges to
make these calls and it was the right
call it's a shame I mean nobody wanted
him to be off sides that would have been
one of the awesomest plays we've ever
seen it stinks that Tony lined up off
sides I mentioned this to start the show
cadarius Tony doesn't have to be
offsides like he doesn't have to be even
pushing the
because his part of the play if it was
designed is to be back you know from
Travis Kelce so he's really kind of
stopped he's in a neutral zone there
neutral area I don't know why he felt
the need to get out and it if he was
going to the end zone then I get it but
he wasn't he probably went down 10 yards
and sort of stopped and then Kelsey got
the ball but I don't know if this was a
designed play or
not what do you think
I that's a really good question I think
it was built in to the play but I don't
think Kelsey just did that on a whim I
think it was built in as an option or a
possibility I'm actually surprised given
the fact that there were multiple
Defenders around Kelce that he had the
guts to pull it off and actually throw
it it was amazing you know one thought I
had watching that Dan I feel like on
some
level this will be the next thing in the
sport of football you know how like we
had the Chip Kelly hurry up and you know
there's always like the next thing you
know the Zone reads the
rpos someone smart and
creative is gonna is gonna and it's not
gonna be all the time it's not gonna but
they're gonna have a couple plays a game
where they're gonna have built-in
laterals like this almost like built-in
hooking ladders and have some success
with it why wouldn't you try that
especially if you're a lesser team we're
talking to Ross Tucker Westwood W CBS
Sports NFL college football analyst he
was on the call of Army Navy on Saturday
doesn't matter where they play that
atmosphere you know they bring that
atmosphere when they bring in the the
cadets and that was and of course you
get down to a fourth and goal stop uh at
the goal I mean it was awesome it was
wonderful Dan it's it's my single
favorite day of the year every year tell
everybody if you haven't been you got to
go I don't know why then but ever once I
get to the stadium my chest is like this
the whole time I'm just like so full of
Pride and patriotism the entire game
seeing every Cadet every midshipman The
energy they bring I don't know how they
do it I don't know if they Rigg the game
or what but it comes down to the last
play every year it's unbelievable that
it come down to the last play every year
and uh it was just a fantastic fantastic
day highly recommend and you know what's
crazy I don't know you know this but
they were telling me before the game it
was the second highest ticket in the
history of Gillette Stadium the last
thing I had seen on my app on my phone
it was
$787 was the cheapest ticket to get in
the only more expensive ticket more than
any Patriot game ever any AFC
Championship Game the only more
expensive ticket was Taylor Swift in the
summer so the two most expensive tickets
to Gillette Stadium in the history of
the stadium supposedly are Taylor Swift
and the Army Navy game how much trouble
are the Eagles
in oh that's a good question um I don't
think they're in that much trouble in
the sense that their schedule gets a lot
easier now and they have a month to kind
of figure this out so from that
standpoint you know we knew they were
having a tough stretch Dan and I said at
the start of it three- two would be
great if they went three and two it's
weird though because they they won the
first three and lost the last like if
they flipped it you'd be feeling good
about them right now they beat the
Cowboys they beat the Chiefs they beat
the bills but now these last two losses
and the way they've lost them you know I
think they'll figure out the Red Zone
stuff on offense I don't think they'll
fumble three times in the opponent's
territory the defense is concerning the
the defense right now the D Line's not
as dominant as they need to be they have
issues on the back seven it's gonna be
weird because there's a pretty decent
chance they win these next four games
they go 14 and three and does that mean
we feel like they fixed it or that they
solved it or does it just mean they
played the Giants twice and the Arizona
Cardinals and we won't really know till
they go against the Cowboys boys or the
ners in the playoffs again if you had to
pick today between the Cowboys and ners
best team in the
NFC oh
ners yeah the ners I mean I give the
Cowboys a lot of credit for the way
they're performing they're doing a heck
of a job but the ners they blew the
Eagles out and I know the Cowboys won by
20 points but I mean AJ Brown had a ball
in his hands in the end zone Devonte
Smith had a ball in his hands in the end
zone the Cowboys kicker made two 60 yard
field goals the Eagles fumbled three
times inside the Cowboys 40 yard line
like that game could have been more
competitive could have been closer and I
think the ners are G to have HomeField
Advantage so they're only have to win
two home games to go to the Super I
think the Niners are the best team in
football right now and I think it's
probably by a decent margin but we'll
see who stays healthy we'll see how
they're playing at the end of this thing
you're doing the Vikings and the Bengals
on
Saturday yeah two teams teams that have
seven wins and I think they might both
be in the playoffs right now or at least
they're certainly in the playoff mix
with I'm guessing it'll be Nick Mullen I
think the Josh dobs thing is over and
how about this Jake Browning Dan I know
he's only has three starts in the NFL
80% completion he's completing eight
like the Bengals are actually a real
thing and a real possibility to still
make the playoffs with Jake Browning
which is wild and then the Zack Wilson
story I it's it's just this is reality
TV because reality TV isn't really
reality TV because it's scripted what
Zack Wilson the Jets the whole story The
Leak everything teammates and then
you're going against CJ Stout and then
yeah of course he's going to throw a
couple of touchdown passes and look
awesome
here yeah and then I mean I would love
to see like what some of his prop bets
are for this next game you know what I
mean like because there's some people
that are going to think Zach can do it
again and they're gonna they're going to
be part of it there's other people think
nah I've seen this movie way way too
many times I'm he's gonna come crashing
down give me the under on the Jets and
whoever they play in the next game great
to talk to you save travels thank you
buddy always thank you that's Ross
Tucker good buddy the Ros Tucker
football podcast you can find him on
social media at Ros Tucker NFL so